bonsoir belgique certains convoyeurs
donc de la liberté ont pris la direction
de strasbourg d'autres devraient le
faire dans les prochaines heures
effectivement est ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que ce soir l'engouement espéré a
été plutôt moindre ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'hier à lille où plus de 1300
véhicules ont été signalés par les
forces de l'ordre et bien certains ont
pris la route de strasbourg d'autres
celle de bruxelles ait d'autres encore
celle de leur domicile d'où une
mobilisation tronquée dispatcher un
manque d'organisation également
responsable de cette fin en eau de
boudin ce matin le maire de la ville
belge estimait le nombre de véhicules à
400 ou 500 plus d'une trentaine ont été
interceptés il avait prévenu qu'aucun
blocage ne sera tolérée c'est plus ou
moins ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
dans la capitale belge qui a interdit
cette mobilisation le dispositif de
sécurité a été renforcée à les
convoyeurs de la liberté se sont réunis
une première fois place sainte catherine
en début d'après midi les forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues immédiatement
à noter plusieurs arrestations et
quelques échauffourées le rassemblement
a rapidement été dispersés mais à ce
moment apprécié bien la motivation était
toujours dans les rangs écoutez
je passe la litterna aucune raison
d'être pour vous pour moi mes enfants et
pour qu'on arrive tout ça parce que là
ça n'a pu le vaccin n'a plus lieu d'être
ses cales turcotte qu'on va voir nous
allons vivre que comme ça maintenant on
nous parle du passeport à la chinoise
regarder les rapports du sénat en france
c'est déjà écrit c'est déjà prêt y'a
plus qu'à mettre en application non on
est contre tous à retrouver ce que nous
avions avant quoi pouvoir les boire un
café vous et moi sans avoir besoin de
présenter un qr code aller faire ses
courses normalement
voilà je pense que beaucoup de gens sont
concernés je vois peu de monde bouge et
c'est triste mais cela va aller plus
vite qu'on ne le croit on veut
simplement que ça s'arrête pour
reprendre une vie normale en changeant
quelques règles par contre que tous ceux
qui nous gouvernent les corons plus haut
depuis cinq jours payés de ce qu'ils ont
fait surtout s'habille en liberté pour
venir ici pour défendre nos droits le
droit à l'information le droit de là
santé à choisir le traitement qui nous
est donnée pas une obligation qui est
discriminante mais en europe on est
censé être en démocratie
d'accord on est censé vivre libre et là
on est victime de lois liberticides et
dites vous que si nous on est là c'est
clair non on est des citoyens qui
étaient à ce nous étions à insérer dans
la société nous accomplissions et nous
accomplissons encore nos devoirs et on
nous enlève nos droits donc on doit
continuer à se battre et clairement on
est des milliers et des milliers mais
s'il faut continuer on continuera ça
fait sept mois en france qu'on est dans
les rues il pleut ménages y vante les
gens ils sont tous dans les rues ils
arrivent ils sont la bise vous l'avez vu
tout à l'heure on se connaît tous on est
une communauté tellement énorme c'est la
plus grande erreur qu'ils ont fait c'est
politique vous avez fait sa grande
erreur vous nous avez réuni et
aujourd'hui on est éveillé on est des
êtres qui ont une intelligence
collective qui allons le diffuser aux
autres îles faisant de plus en plus au
fur et à mesure des mois suite à ce
premier rassemblement est bien là les
manifestants ont ensuite tenté de se
rapprocher de la commission européenne
mais là encore la police est intervenue
rapidement plusieurs personnes
interpellées certaines de manière assez
musclé et enfin une dernière tentative a
eu lieu ici un place du luxembourg non
loin de la commission là les autorités
se sont montrées pull plus virulente
quelques gaz lacrymogènes ont été tirés
elle est canon à eau utilisée de manière
à partiel ce qui a à disperser
définitivement les manifestants qui se
sont retrouvés de manière assez
sporadiques dans des bars comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi et qu'ils
poursuivent pour certains encore une
fois ce convoi de la liberté alors
maintenant comme je vous le disais à une
possible action est prévue demain à
strasbourg plusieurs convois tente de
rallier le parlement européen afin
d'interpeller les euro députés en
commission jusqu'à jeudi mais là aussi
la préfète du bas-rhin était très clair
un josiane chevalier a pris un arrêté
interdisant toute manifestation non
déclarée dès qu'on vend qui passe
vaccinale la préfète a donné des
consignes de fermeté comme ici les
forces de l'ordre pourront verbaliser et
interpeller les contrevenants vous
l'aurez compris à la fin de ce périple
du du convoi de la liberté a été
entachée quelque peu par une certaine
répression policière merci david kelly
file